mais tous sensibles aux jeunes
et en racheter pour les stages d'avant
plus tabou ah non j'ai pas remplie le
tableau et j'ai quelqu'un
de souscription ramed 95
et une petite fille de 4 ans puis le
parti à celle qu'il a quitté pas fan je
faisais mon allocution
[Musique]
et monf la rencontre et je rencontrais
qui la
font les autres
et là tu as quel âge leila quatre ans et
demi hu
c'est un petit bisou
je réalise pas sûr at elle
alors oui les bisous les bons jours à
chelles pourquoi j'ai tout le temps les
la woody et le sommeil
mais si tu crois un jour 50 pâte à
prendre qu'à stage assad absolument rien
dire tu fais semblant ne pas comprendre
que je m'attache à n afin d'ajouter
c'est vous son père et sa mère pour
toujours et je resterai une figurante
exagère
[Musique]
je me suis dit moi si je peux tu vas
encore des enfants le problème c'est
qu'en du feu tour dp du tout quoi toi
c'est trop tard
oui
[Musique]
si vous voulez l'enfant c'est maintenant
hoyau verra à vie courte et longue oui
la vie est longue
[Musique]